سجلت صادرات سلطنه عمان السلعيه غير نفطيه
ارتفاعا قدر بنسبه
48.6% لتبلغ قيمتها اربعه مليارات اكثر من
اربعه مليارات ريال عماني بنهايه شهر
اغسطس الماضي حازت المنتجات المعدنيه
لقيمه الاكبر من الصادرات السلعيه غير
النفطيه لتبلغ حتى نهايه اغسطس الماضي
مقيمتها اكثر من مليار ريال عماني ثلاثه
منتجات المعادن العاديه ومصنوعاتها بقيمه
صادرات تصل الى اكثر من مليار ريال عماني
من مسقط ينضم الينا وفد العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي اهلا عبد الرحمن يعني اولا
ماذا تعني هذه الارقام بالنسبه لعمان
خالد اهلا وسهلا بك هل هذه ارقام تعني
تعافي كبير في الاقتصاد العماني الي سيما
بعد ان عمان لديها موقع استراتيجي مميز
فهي البوابه الجنوبيه للخليج العربي ومضيق
هرمز الذي تدخل منه الكثير من البضائع الى
دول الخليج همم ايضا هذا المضيق مقابل
لموانع عمان سابع زميلي وليد ياخذ لكم بعض
اللقطات نحن الان نقف امام همم ميناء مسقط
هذا الميناء التاريخي الذي تحول الى وجهها
سياحيه بعد نقل الاشرطه التجاريه الى
ميناء صحار الصناعي هناك موانع كثيره خالد
في عمان اذا ما تحدثنا عن ميناء صلاله
الذي يعد من ابرز الموانئ العالميه ايضا
بناء الدقم الذي بدا في 2011 بتشغيل
التجريبي للحوض الجاف وبدا بتصنيع السفن
ايضا عندك بناء صحار ايضا الذي يبعد 240
كيلو تقريبا على العاصمه العمانيه من خصب
الذي يقع في
مسندم ايضا همم مقابل للموانع الايرانيه
وايضا اا يعتبر من احد المداخل الرئيسيه
الى موانع قطر والبحرين والكويت بالاضافه
الى طبعا ميناء شناص هناك تعافي كبير
اقتصاديا مهم جدا اذا ما تحدثنا بالارقام
خالد وعن الوالدات تحديدا المنافذ البحريه
استحودت على اهم صادرات العمانيه والقيمه
الاعلى من اجمالي الواردات السلعيه لعمان
بنهايه اغسطس الماضي سجلت سبعه مليار ريال
عماني اي تقريبا 70 مليار
سعودي والمنافذ الجويه ايضا ضمت حوالي 901
مليون ريال عماني هناك تعارف كبير ايضا
على القطاع السياحي نحن الان من امام سوق
مطرح الشعبي هذا السوق الذي يمتد عمره لا
اكثر من 200 عام نلاحظ الحركه الاقتصاديه
انه راح هذا ايضا ملابه انتباهي خالد
العدد الكبير من السياح والعله كاس العالم
في قطر ايضا
الكثير من السياح للقدوم الى سلطنه عمان
خاصه ان السلطات العمانيه اتاحت لمن يحمل
بطاقه هيا بالدخول الى الاراضي العمانيه
بدون تاشيره فهذا شجع الكثير من السياحه
ايضا خاصه الاوروبيين والفود الاوروبيه ان
تزور عمان خاصه ان تقريبا ساعه ودقائق
بسيطه عن الدوحه هناك ايضا خطط استراتيجيه
بالنسبه لرؤيه عمان 20 40 لمحاوله ضخ
المزيد من الاستثمارات في القطاع
الاقتصادي والسياحي وايضا المزيد من
الواردات والصادرات ايضا خاصه الصناعات
البتروكيماويه وايضا المشتقات النفطيه
فيما يتعلق بسلطنه همم عمان هناك ايضا
تفاعل كبير يبدين محللين اقتصاديين تجاه
الاقتصاد العماني خلال الفتره القليله
المقبله لا سيما في ظل همم التغيرات همم
التشريعات الاقتصاديه المهمه التي اتخذتها
حكومه عمان خلال الفتره القليله الماضيه
للتعافي من جائحه كورونا وما اتبعها ايضا
من الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه في اطار
الخطه المعتمده يعني لتنميه التطوير
الاقتصاد العماني الى اي مدى ممكن ان يكون
هذا عامل فاعل بالاضافه طبعا للاستفاده من
موقع الجغرافيا
كذلك كل ما يتعلق تقريبا بصادرات غير
النفطيه في عمان
سلطنه عمان على تعزيز الشركات مع الدول
يعني عمان هي شريك من اهم الشركات مثلا
اليابان الى جانب الصين كوريا الجنوبيه
ايضا الهند هناك ايضا استفاده كبيره من
موانع عمان الموجوده على امتداد الساحل
الخليج العربي وايضا موقع عمال استراتيجي
جعل الكثير من الدول تبادل الى عقد شركات
مع سلطنه عمان الى جانب ايضا خالد الحرص
الكبير من الحكومه العمانيه على التوظيف
الشباب العماني نعرف ان سلطنه عمان كانت
همم هناك لديها مشاكل فيما يتعلق
بالباحثين عن العمل والعدد الكبير للشباب
لكن رؤيه 20 40 العمانيه ساهمت بحد كبير
في توظيف الكثير من العمانيين الاسبوع
الماضي يحتفلت عمان بعيدها الوطني ومن
خلال هذه الاعياد تم الاعلان عن عشره
مشاريع استراتيجيه عمانيه من المتوقع ان
توظف الاف الشباب العمانيين خلال السنوات
القليله المقبله لا الى بالاضافه الى طبعا
رؤيتها الطموح الاقتصاديه لتعزيز الشركات
مع مع العديد من الدول التي همم ربما تضخ
الكثير من الاستثمارات داخل السلطه
شكرا جزيلا لك من مسقط منفذ العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي